guys know who Andrew Tate is yeah do you  know who he is yeah do we like him do we  not like him no why not they've  misogynist can you define misogyny none  of them woman have you heard him say men  are better than women though everything  he said is like when you're out with a  man would you like him to sort of lead  and maybe pay for you no like 50 50. so  since we're all equal and say you're on  a date with a guy and another man comes  and tries to like slap your bum what  would you expect your man to do he  should like stick up for it why now he's  putting himself in the firing line yeah  but where you go why don't you put  yourself in the firing line but only  equal when it comes to buying dinner  no